hello believe nation today I'm going to
share with you the best way to get a
guess from an email so as entrepreneurs
we do a lot of selling and marketing via
email we want our emails to get open we
want email to be responded to want
people to take action every time we send
an email out to people and when I was
doing my campaigns from my book I
connected with a lot of people who are
on the fringe of my network via email I
got a lot of people to support me and
take action and I even got one person
writing back to me saying this was the
single best written requests for support
email I've ever seen and this guy is
seeing a lot it led to me getting the
podcast interview with him and led to a
Forbes article being written about my
book and so let's a lot of opportunities
all because i sent one really
well-crafted email you guys want to see
what i wrote i'm going to share it with
you today and hopefully you can learn
from it as well and apply it to your
business so as an extra point of context
the guy wrote this tuesday with kevin
cruise i did an interview with him on my
channel over a year ago i had not been
in touch since there's been 12 months of
radio silence and here i was reaching
out trying to ask for his support and
promote my book he was what i wrote hi
kevin thanks again for the phone
interview last year my fav comment was
incredibly good and informative video
Thank You Evan and thank you mr. Cruz
you have a new subscription for me this
comes at a perfect time I wanted to
quickly touch base because I just
launched my first book and I could
really use your help it's called your
one word the powerful safety to creating
the business and life that matter and
I've been endorsed by gary vaynerchuk
lewis howes James Altucher among others
more quickly found here and i'll link
the website so finding your one word
your 12 core value and then building a
life and business around it like i have
for around believe i know it's going to
seem greedy of me but I was wondering
what's the change it could help me reach
more people it could be through an
article a video and introduction or
basically anything that you think might
help spread the message I'm asking
because I respect you and also believe
in a message of the book so much that
anyone you connected to will be an
easily thankful it's not I totally get
it and I'm happy to support your work in
the future so that was the email I'm
reading it on my phone here let me break
down
different elements of it to explain why
it works so well so to start I'm just
thanking him right thanks again for the
front of you last year kind of reminding
the point of contact he may have
forgotten development he may not
remember who I am quite off we meet so
many people in the course of a year that
is easy to forget some people and so if
you've met them at an event that you had
coffee you had a foot phone call you've
been exchanging emails and spend a long
time just reminding them the context of
which you're reaching out how you guys
have already met before or to be
introduced by somebody else putting that
on their radar immediately so they know
where you're coming from next up i
shared a comment and I did this for
everybody that I interviewed over the
past couple years of my channel I tried
to share one good thing to make him feel
really good so this person left a
comment it was a good and informative
video thanking us we got a new
subscription and so I wanted to make him
feel good about that thing that we did a
year ago remind you about how good it
was again in case you forgot then I
wanted to get into the book and I
explained quickly what it was about I
explained who had endorsed it I
explained a little bit of the content
and it provided a link to more
information in kc care didn't want to
get into you know three pages long about
why the book is so great just a quick
statement about what it is what it's
called who's endorsed it and then a link
to find out more information so after I
introduced the book I wanted to ask for
help the next line I pulled from Lewis
houses youtube channel he had this great
guy on who was an FBI negotiator and
this was the line that he recommends
using in business negotiations saying I
know it's going to seem greedy of me but
I was wondering what's the change to get
help me reach more people and that
disarms them and opened them up to being
willing to help then I was just trying
to give some examples so it could do an
article of video and introduction
anything that we think of that may help
spread the message I don't want to be so
specific and say to your newsletter list
because one maybe he doesn't have a
newsletter list or two maybe doesn't you
know want to send it out to thermal is
basically anything is he could think of
to help me with the book I would really
appreciate it then I flatter him a
little bit right I'm asking because I
respect you and also believe in the
message of the book so much that anyone
you connected to will be immediately
thankful there's a lot of value in the
book and I really respect him and then
they end on it not being a hard sell so
if not I totally get it and I'm happy to
support your work in
future and so not forcing him to do it
showing that i really respect his time
in his opinion and I'd be really
grateful for his support and so this
really helped me get a lot of
endorsements get a lot of support do a
lot of introduction to a lot of
connections and also Kevin himself
saying that it was the single best
written requests for support email have
ever seen and that leading to his
podcast interview and the Forbes
interview as well and so hopefully you
can learn from that structure applied to
your emails and get a much better result
when you're sending it off to customers
partners investors suppliers potential
influencers to help get yours mess so
that's how I sell via email with a quick
template and example will link up the
text in the description below so you
guys can copy and paste and tweak around
like you want to I'd love to know what
did you take from this what did you
enjoy most about this email do you have
any other email secrets tips strategies
that you want to share please leave that
in the comments below I'm curious to
find out violently I was think of a
quick share this to David venden bloomin
junior thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word it
really really really means a lot to me
and I hope your enjoyment thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love